good morning everybody it is at seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
here on the breakfast show wherever
you're watching us around the world and
I'm in use this morning from Heathrow
County Terror police have launched a
major investigation after uranium was
discovered in a package at the airport
there are reports this morning that
Undeclared nuclear material arrived on a
flight from Oman and was destined for
Iranian Nationals in the UK also ahead
25 000 ambulance drivers paramedics and
call handlers are on strike we'll be
live on a picket line and we'll be
speaking to the health secretary Steve
Barclay in just a few moments time it is
Wednesday the 11th of January
foreign
airport counterterra police are working
to trace everyone who could have been
involved in shipping uranium to the UK
I'm on the picket line in Huddersfield
where uni leaders say they are providing
life and limb cover but NHS bosses warn
that the service will struggle to cope
also ahead westminster's next big
Scandal Sky News reveals concerns about
tens of millions flowing into the
all-party Parliamentary groups much of
it from lobbyists
at least 17 people are dead and tens of
thousands told to leave their homes as
storms batter California
in his latest television interview in
the U.S Prince Harry accuses the media
of lying for what he said in his book
about killing Taliban
without doubt the most dangerous lie
that they have told is that I somehow
boasted about the number of people that
I killed in Afghanistan
coming up later we'll be speaking to the
team of scientists who've developed a
special camera to catch poachers Plus
foreign
County terrorism police are
investigating the discovery of material
contaminated with uranium at London's
Heathrow Airport the Undeclared material
arrived on a flight from Oman and was
reportedly destined for Iranian
Nationals here in the UK police are
working urgently to trace everyone who
was involved in the shipment what on
Earth has been going on there let's find
out more should we Usher standing by for
us at Heathrow this morning tell us what
you know
we know that this package arrived at
Heathrow on the 29th of December
according to the sun it was on a flight
that had arrived into terminal 4 from
Oman and that it was in the hold of a
passenger jet uh the report details that
the package was found after specialist
scanners detected it whilst it was on
the way to a freight shed and that it's
believed the package originated from
Pakistan now the home office hasn't
commented however there has been a
statement released from the Metropolitan
Police and in that statement Commander
Richard Smith has said I want to assure
the public that the amount of
contaminated material was extremely
small and has been assessed by experts
as posing no threat to the public
Although our investigation remains
ongoing from our inquiries so far it
does not appear to be linked to any
direct threat as the public would expect
however we will continue to follow up on
all of available lines of inquiry to
ensure that this is definitely the case
so understandably something like this
would cause concern but I think the
important takeaways and reassurances
from that message from the Metropolitan
Police are the fact that it was a very
small amount of uranium detected in this
package that it isn't linked to any
known threat and that it's believed that
it will not pose any danger to the
public
okay for now thanks so much indeed some
breaking news just reaching us here at
Sky Center via the Reuters news agency
we're hearing that a man has injured
several people with a weapon in the
Paris Garden nor station
um the suspect we're told has been
neutralized by the police shot dead I'm
guessing uh that according to the France
Media Station several people injured we
have no idea at this stage as to what
level of injury but it has happened this
morning neutralized by the police will
get more information on that and we will
update you as soon as we we can on that
unfolding story here on Sky news this
morning
meantime people in England and Wales are
being urged only to call an ambulance if
a life is at risk for anything less use
your GP call the NHS 111 service or
visit a pharmacy that's because around
25 000 paramedics ambulance drivers and
call center handlers are on strike today
and NHS bosses are warning that the
service will struggle to cope uh let's
get more should we with Fraser who's
standing by for us at an ambulance Depot
in Huddersfield this morning hi Fraser
tell us more
good morning okay yeah well this strike
started just after midnight uh here in
Huddersfield and across much of England
and into Wales as well still quite a bit
of support from passing motorists
hearing a lot of horns being blown as
they drive past the picket line here but
we're here again aren't we a sense of
deja vu who had strikes in the ambulance
service just before Christmas something
that we hadn't seen in a generation and
still the talks are stumbling I can have
a chat now with Peter Davis from the GMB
Union one of the unions on strike here
today in West Yorkshire so there were
some talks on Monday no progress though
well there's no progress I mean it was a
I think those talks were more for show
for the public than they were for us
we've got absolutely nothing out of
those talks there are no promises it was
just the government trying to kick the
can down the road to a later date they
talked about a future pay rise perhaps
being brought forward that was the
headline in the media but there was
nothing solid on the table we've got a
government who on the face of it are
telling the public that they're talking
to us and they want to resolve this but
in reality the door's not open and there
are just been there's been no nothing
that's come to the table
so we're hearing about different levels
of cover that are being offered in
different areas category one are covered
right across the strike areas those are
the most serious life-threatening
situations category two that's still a
little bit unsure isn't it could include
heart attacks and strokes no guarantee
that an ambulance will turn out how do
you determine what's going to happen
well the managers determine whether it
is life or Limb and we trust the
managers
to send our members out on life and limb
calls we're not here to endanger the
public we're here to highlight the fact
that you know these workers and the NHS
Ambulance Service in particular is on
its knees this doesn't seem to be a day
go by when we're not switching the TV on
or opening the paper and seeing cues and
queues of ambulances and I've been
talking to some of these workers on this
picket line today you know who are
getting really you know really angry
about what's happening to their service
we've got you know depending on which
figures you look at there are around 150
000 vacancies in in the NHS this crisis
this this winter crisis that the
government keep telling us we're facing
isn't a really a winter crisis talk to
these workers this crisis is an ongoing
crisis throughout the year and it gets
worse and worse every winter we've got a
Workforce there on their knees and these
workers are just out there to get them
and you can hear we've got massive
public support and and you know they're
here to to fight for an NHS which is
which is
crumbling so he's going to be talking to
the health secretary shortly what would
you say to him directly if you could
well I'd say you get serious you know we
want to resolve this dispute you know go
go in coming out with with ideas about
changing legislation to take the workers
rights away from them to do this is not
the answer that would that's just gonna
you know infuriate our members further
we want the government to get around the
table get serious
negotiate with us and let's get a
settlement and let's get these workers
back to work thank you thanks very much
I'll let you get back to the Brazier get
warmed up a little bit chilly here in
Huddersfield this morning so there you
are okay the message from the picket
line here to the health secretary get
serious I heard that loud and clear be
putting that to Steve Barkley very
shortly thanks very much Rosa thank you
the strikes are set to continue
throughout the month should we look at
them in uh more detail today's ambulance
strike will be followed by another in
Wales on the 19th and more strikes in
England and Wales the following week
remember color coded here gives you an
idea of what's going on nurses in
England plan to be back on the picket
lines on the 18th and the 19th rail
workers on London's Elizabeth line
they'll be on strike tomorrow that's the
red one there you go and bus drivers in
some parts of the capital are striking
for six more days this month work at the
environment agency will take industrial
action for the first time in the
organization's history that's on the
18th of this month and teachers across
Scotland will walk out today with
regional Scottish strikes from the 16th
onwards that is the um what we call that
fuchsia I'm going to call that fuchsia
this morning let's take a look at how
the papers are reporting the NHS crisis
should we the times reads a thousand
excess deaths each week as the NHS
buckles the express headline has a
warning from nurses to the PM that the
clock is ticking to do a deal
the Metro describes proposed government
legislation designed to limit the
effects of industrial action as a strike
against strikes that's the Metro for you
and the eye reports six million workers
face new strike ban as ambulance staff
walk out also the guardian hears that in
response unions are planning a
coordinated day of action
Daily Mail there for you as well
in other news for you this morning
Prince Harry has said military veterans
should be able to talk without shame
about their experiences speaking in a TV
interview he blamed the press for taking
comments in his new book revealing he
killed 25 Taliban fighters in
Afghanistan out of context
without doubt the most dangerous lie
that they have told is that I somehow
boasted about the number of people that
I killed in Afghanistan I've read that
section of the book and I'm without
reading the entire thing right here it
is it to me it's it's a very thoughtful
description of what that knowledge is
like to have and what the experience is
to know that you have done this in order
to protect what you believe is good in
the world from those who would wish to
destroy it there's there's nothing
boastful about it
um and not only but also I would say
that if I heard anybody else
if I hurt anyone boasting about that
kind kind of thing I would be angry but
but it's a lie and hopefully now that
the book is out people will be able to
see the context and it is it's it's
really it's really troubling and very
disturbing that they can get away with
it and also because they had the context
it wasn't like a it wasn't like here's
just one lion they had the whole section
they ripped it away and just said here
it is he's boasting on this
Laura is um with us this morning
um so how was it taken out of context
did he killed 25 people well he said it
was the one line the papers the press
the media took out of his 407-page
Memoir they said they Stripped Away the
rest of the information around they took
the context basically completely
disregarded it and just reported the
fact that he says he killed 25 people I
mean if you look at some of the other
information in there he does describe uh
the people he killed as chess players
within a game chess pieces
um and he'd I mean he don't look on the
one how he does explain look we had to
look at it that I was doing this for
good
but on the other hand the facts are laid
bare and the reaction from really senior
military personnel after he revealed
that that specific number was you
shouldn't have done this you're putting
your family potentially at risk you
could even be putting the safety of the
Invictus games in Germany this year at
risk why would you give so much
information I mean he obviously explains
there that having spent a lot of time
with veterans having got to know them
the challenges they face or having you
know taken part in active service it's
this huge risk of suicide and he thinks
by speaking out it will help that
um how does saying how many people you
killed on the battlefield
um help others I think he thinks by
talking about things honestly openly how
it came to that the mindset you're in
when you're in the theater of war that
that accounts for it as I say there's
been a lot of comment the other way
especially from people in the military
saying you shouldn't have said it you
went too far with this hopefully
potentially how area said everything
he's going to say now we've had the last
this is the last of his interview so it
feels like we've been talking about this
book these interviews for a very long
time now this is it he said his piece
he's obviously angry he said I I it's
been very hurtful and challenging the
fact that Memoirs got leaked blame the
press for that I would blame the Spanish
bookshops personally that put it on
their shelves last Thursday by mistake
um now he's got to go away get on with
what he wants to be doing now and the
Royal what that is
he says he wants to carry on the work
they're doing with their Foundation
championing the causes they want he's
hinted perhaps at a return to the
Commonwealth in some kind of role him
and Megan both had really prominent
roles in the Commonwealth before and
they had to give those up when they left
left their lives working lives in the
Royal Family
look the royal family themselves haven't
said anything still haven't said
anything not expecting them to
definitely won't they'll be out and
about later this week um the king
probably expect other senior members of
the family out and about you know
getting on with the job they'll be
hoping that despite you know the huge
number of grenades Harry has been
throwing at them in this book very very
private moments I mean we we hear such
intimate details don't we I know you
finished the book as well and you you
really do get a very behind closed-door
sense of of the conversations of the
moments these private moments they will
be hoping that this will blow away I
mean it's been talked about now non-stop
for five days whether or not that will
happen who knows yeah and the only
remaining question is will they come to
the coronation we asked that yesterday
we both know finished the book what's
your summation I still think I still
think Harry will be there I mean he says
we need this reconciliation that we need
some accountability on behalf of his
father on behalf of his brother as well
if that happens it'll all be private it
will won't be leaked the Press because
we were saying how can anything Harry
says be treated as confidential given
the amount of information he's now
released in his in his book in his in
the interviews but I think he will be
there he will appreciate the moment the
occasion and certainly the king I would
have thought will want him there okay
for now thanks very much indeed another
challenge actually facing him at the
moment is his home there's been some big
problems with flooding in California
particularly the area where he is uh
based
um and we've been reflecting on that
with Martha Kellner
it's difficult to believe that this is
California a state in the grip of
several years of drought that the rains
have arrived with a Vengeance Rivers and
Creeks bursting their Banks trapping
people in their homes and cars the
previously bone dry land cannot cope the
onslaught of water sending mud and rock
Boulders tumbling towards Mountainside
towns
Ray is surveying the damage but didn't
bargain for the cement-like mud you've
got huge Rock mountains everywhere
water just piles up and when it does
this is where it comes given the fact
that we've destroyed and polluted our
our environment beyond all belief
but
human race does what it wants and
Mother Nature will do what she does
whether we like it or not
they're more used to wildfires than
floods around here but some places are
experiencing their wettest 10 days for
more than a century at least 16 people
have died so far a five-year-old boy was
swept away after his mother's car was
trapped in flood water he is still
missing the entire town of Montecito
home to the super wealthy including
Prince Harry and Megan has been
evacuated but not before one of its most
famous residents issued a warning
to our house never flows ever
probably about nine feet up we need to
be nicer than Mother Nature
because nature is not happy with us
major roads across California are
blocked this is sort of impassable at
the moment isn't it it is yeah so last
night my wife and myself we couldn't get
home Jason is trying to get through to
rescue a neighbor who's been bitten by a
dog and needs medical treatment they're
not gonna be able to make it across so
she's wondering if she could just have
one of the other vehicles drive him
across and then shoot my dad might take
him to the hospital
some are seeing the bright side but with
more extreme weather on the way the
worst May yet be to come Martha callner
Sky News Santa Barbara County
I just want to update you on the
breaking news that we brought to you um
just a few moments ago about an incident
at the Paris Garden or train station
this morning
um a man injured several people with a
weapon we believe it was a knife now um
he has subsequently been neutralized by
the police is what we are being told
um
statement saying the from the French
authorities the police would have opened
fire against a threatening person who
would have injured customers in Garden
nor the person was subdued the emergency
services intervened and the person
evacuated a security perimeter has been
established but the station continues to
operate normally is the latest that
we're hearing as far as that is
concerned so there has been an incident
at the Paris GA donor airport train
station forgive me this morning and
several people have been injured by a
man wielding a knife and as a result of
that he has been neutralized we're told
by the police we'll get more information
on that and we will update you of course
as soon as we can
meantime Let's uh bring in the health
secretary Steve Barclay good morning
it's good to see you as always thanks
for joining us on the program just
hearing what's happening there at the
Parry Garden or airport
um airport train station How concerned
are you about what we've heard about
what's happening at Heathrow Airport as
well we heard that there was some
material that anti-terror police were
involved in and and I don't know what's
happening well I'm obviously learning
about this uh this morning and clearly
there's an investigation underway and
it's right that that looks at all the
issues and I'm sure it will report in
due course okay
um obviously very alarming for a lot of
people this morning but as you say
information's still coming in on that
what we can say in other matters
particularly as far as your brief is
concerned 50 000 more deaths in the NHS
over the past 12 months why is that well
all countries are looking across Europe
facing a similar issue is what is the
consequence of the pandemic clearly
during the pandemic there will be some
patients who delayed treatment
particularly we're seeing some of that
play through in pressure on
cardiovascular conditions there'll be
some directly linked some of those
deaths to covid itself some of it may be
indirectly where for example someone's
waiting for treatment we've got a
challenge in terms of people waiting for
operations that were working very
actively to clear so it's extremely
complicated as to what the driver of
those excess deaths are that's something
we're looking closely I'm talking to the
chief medical officer how alarmed are
you by those numbers well it's clearly
concerning but it's not something that's
just affecting us in England it's
something I know but all countries 50
000 people dead who apps wouldn't have
been otherwise you must be alarmed well
it's concerning that the VAR those but
clearly we knew at the time of the
pandemic that in order to prevent
further dress that's as a result of
kovid we needed to take a whole range of
very severe actions and and those had an
impact those had an impact in uh further
weights for operations they had an
impact in patients who didn't get
treatment at the time now we've got a
recovery plan in place we cleared the
longest weights the two-year weights
over the summer we're now focused on the
78-week weights and working on those to
get those down so we've invested more in
the Autumn statement an extra 6.6
billion yeah
but obviously the ambulance workers on
strike again today your colleague Grant
chaps saying striking paramedics are
risking lives do you agree with them
well if there's delays to ambulances
obviously it is concerning in terms of
our ability to that that care but we've
been working with the unions
constructively on what cover they will
put in place I'm very pleased that we
have
well it's clearly a concern in terms of
the impact that it has on patient safety
but we're working constructively with
the unions in terms of particularly for
life-threatening calls those most urgent
999 cores and what we're saying to the
public is where there is a genuine
life-threatening urgency the most
important category one calls are being
covered but clearly there'll be wider
pressure on the ambulance system today
so we're saying to people to be mindful
of that but if they do have a
life-threatening condition the most
urging catering one calls are covered
today okay GMB Union had them on the
show just a few moments ago while you
were speaking to some of our colleagues
at other outlets and they're saying
these talks that you've been holding
have been pointless no I think even the
if I take Sarah Gordon who's the the
head of the NHS staff Council she said
after the talks that I had with them on
Monday that there had been progress I'm
seeing the doctor's union today to have
discussions with them we believe Kay
that the right approach is to have the
independent pay-per-view body look at
these issues in terms of what it is not
independent but it is independent and
even the opposition of the independent
pay with your body is describing is
chosen by the Prime Minister and
ministers to choose other people within
that peer review body so it's not
independent well even the the opposition
recognized so labor has said that they
themselves support an independent pay
review body process that's something
that governments of different colors
have had successively for many years
it's able to look at these issues in the
round but we're working constructively
with the unions to see what further
things that we can do that's why we had
the discussions on Monday because we
want to get the evidence for this coming
years pay review body to reflect the
pressures that the system are under and
that's what we were discussing with them
on Monday I told you what the GMB have
said this morning the head of the
national lead for unite saying that you
only wanted to talk about productivity
do you think that NHS workers should
work harder to get their eyes well
productivity is not about working harder
it's about getting the system as a whole
to work better it's about for example
the investment in technology it's about
enabling people who have had training to
be focused on what that training is best
for rather than for example many of
their frustrations with some of the
administrations some of the bureaucracy
some of the things in the system that
are not working as they should and
actually that's common ground with the
trade unions the trend unions say to me
often they are frustrated on behalf of
their members with some of the
inefficiencies in the system so it's
right that we look at where can we work
smarter better in a more effective way
what is the right investment in
technology what is the cost of agents at
the moment and count we look at how we
bring that down so there are areas we
can work together with the trade unions
on that and you use that to make any pay
review body settlement more affordable
in April General Secretary of the TUC
Paul Novak saying that the anti-strike
laws that you want to bring in are
undemocratic what will happen if workers
just ignore these laws and strike anyway
well they say it's undemocratic but lots
of other European countries have them
and I don't hear them saying that France
is undemocratic if people don't if
people ignore break the law basically
and go on strike well firstly what I'm
saying is is lots of other European
countries have these so when people say
it's undemocratic it is something that
they have in France they have in Italy
they have in Spain and I don't think
anyone's seriously suggesting these
countries are undemocratic but what
we're saying is if we look at the way
the ocn have approached National
arrangements for the strikes they've
acted very responsibly to to be fair to
them in terms of having a national
arrangement in place
of prime minister Barkley as you know
what will you do if workers break the
law and go on strike well this is about
having a safety net there as they do in
other European countries to ensure that
there are minimum safety levels minimum
service levels in place we will debate
this in Parliament in terms of how this
will apply we're just looking at
ambulances in the first instance in
terms of health
it's about it's not going to prosecute
it's about their behavior much more of
the unions it's about the behavior of
the unions more than individual members
so for example there's a marked
difference between what we've seen with
the RCN who have had National
Arrangements in place to guarantee
safety and what we've seen with the
ambulance strikes where even up to
midnight last night I was getting calls
in terms of what Arrangements would be
in place in terms of the local cover the
minimum safety levels that will be in
place because the ambulance unions have
refused to do that at a national level
and my concern is patient safety that is
what my question is how would you
implement this law if people go on
strike and it's against the law breaking
the law what do you do well as they do
in other European countries it's about
having a safety net that applies to the
behavior of the trade unions
we're going to debate this it'll
probably take about six months in
Parliament for the legislation to pass
so we were screwed this will be
scrutinized we will debate this in
Parliament but it's about saying we want
to be in a position to have national
minimum safety levels in place just as
they do in France in Spain in Italy what
do you accept that the NHS is on its
knees on your watch well it's under huge
pressure but that's not just in England
if you look at what the first Minister
said on Monday Scottish hospitals are
near completely full if you look at
Wales more than 50 000 people waiting
more than two years for an operation if
you look at my counterpart in France he
said that I mean in terms of people in
England who you represent and they feel
that the NHS is on its knees do you
acknowledge that the NHS is under huge
pressure and I acknowledge that uh in
the House of Commons more than Monday
well more so because of the pandemic
because of the combination of uh the
delayed discharge the people in hospital
who are fit to leave and have been
delayed we recognize that with the extra
funding we're putting in place in the
Autumn statement on top of that you've
got around 9 000 people over 9000 people
in hospital recovered and then we had
this massive surge as they did across
Europe with flu cases over Christmas a
seven-fold increase compared to November
there's a hundred times more patients in
hospital with flu this year compared yes
I've had both and if I could make One
Plea to any members we've extended the
number of people that can have access to
the job and if there's any of your
viewers particularly over 50 or in the
cohorts that are at risk who haven't had
their vaccination if we'll make a plea k
for them are you looking at me and
saying anyone anyone anyone who's not
had their their job who is is watching
this uh if I could urgency okay well
when I get to 50 I might do it thanks
thanks very much it's good to see you as
always thanks very much indeed thanks
for joining us
um let's look at these pictures should
we eat from Huddersfield as we speak and
the General Secretary of the GMB Union
Rachel Harrison will be joining us
shortly we've been hearing from the
health secretary there he was making his
point that he was working until midnight
last night to try to avert this strike
which has gone ahead um his colleague
Grant shafts the business secretary
suggesting to us that lives are put at
risk because uh ambulance workers are on
strike this morning
um we'll get more on that we will update
you further Amanda is with us now hi
Amanda alarming that this 50 000 extra
deaths oh sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry
Rachel forgive me I didn't look at you
sitting down let me put that to you 50
000 extra deaths how much of that do you
think could be the responsibility of
ambulance workers going on strike
I think what we what we've actually seen
is across the NHS and the ambulance
services day in and day out our people
are suffering patients are suffering and
that's regularly reported by the
associate Association of ambulance Chief
Executives who report that patient
safety standards are suffering as a
result of the crisis that our NHS has
been put at risk because of these
strikes lives have been put at risk
every single day because of these
strikes no not because of these strikes
and I think what these Grant shops are
on to say that that they are I
absolutely do disagree with what what
grunt shops has said is because I can
guarantee you that GMB local teams and
representatives across the country have
worked around the clock with local
employers to make sure that emergency
procedures are in place on the last
strike day what we actually saw was
paramedics emergency care assistance and
others leaving the picket lines to go
and attend to emergencies so our members
do not want to put lives at risk but
what they're saying to us is lives are
being put at risk every single day
regardless of the strikes and that is
one of the issues how do you feel that
people are being asked not to call an
ambulance unless it's life or death
today
well ambulances are there for emergency
cover and I think that and you know what
what we saw on the last strike today was
a significant reduction in calls to
ambulance services because the public
are behind our members on this and what
they did they heeded the warnings and
they only called it ambulances in
emergencies so obviously people are
giving advice if people are in need of
emergency care what we would say to
people is still contact the emergency
services our members are still there
there are measures in place to make sure
that the most immediate of emergencies
are dealt with so if somebody needs an
ambulance contact an ambulance where are
we with the anti-strike laws we heard
there from the health secretary and he
was saying that they work very
effectively in other parts of Europe
well obviously there was announcement
made in Parliament yesterday we'll look
at the bill in detail as it progresses
through the parliament we're obviously
very anti that and we will campaign
against that I think what I found most
shocking about the speech that was made
yesterday was
um some mistruths in there about the
fact that ambulance or our ambulance
members didn't put safety measures in
place during the last strike which which
was incorrect when you say Miss Truth
you mean lies well Miss Jones it wasn't
correct it wasn't factual what they said
when they referenced the ambulance
services had not put minimum
um safety levels in place we we did
um and I suppose what I'd like to
question is the bill progresses through
Parliament is what is their definition
of minimum safety levels what's yours
it's certainly not what it is currently
you know we've got 135 000 vacancies
um across the NHS we are not able to
deliver the standards of care that our
members want to be able to deliver
because of the Staffing crisis across
the NHS so I would question are we
operating at safe Staffing levels on a
day-to-day basis regardless of any
legislation that the government wants to
put through to take away the right to
strive from our members
uh we heard there from the health
secretary again that he was saying that
he was working until late last night to
try to avert the strike were you
I work around the clock
um what we actually did um GMB called
off the strike on the 28th of December
we had a second day of action planned we
called that off to give
um our show of support back to the
public because we were overwhelmed with
their support to us so we wanted them to
enjoy their Christmas break but we said
to the government we are here around the
clock to to try and resolve this come to
us and talk to us they left it until
Monday this week to have those
conversations with us so they're the
ones that left it too late we have been
here 24 hours a day seven days a week
available to meet with the government
because they've chosen not to talk to us
about pay until this week it's on them
that this strike action goes ahead what
do you want we want a genuine offer that
will recognize it's for the government
to make that offer so when we entered
yeah but when we entered the pay review
body process 12 months ago in good faith
what we asked for at that time was a
significant increase in Pay
um a commitment to restoring a decade of
lost earnings and an immediate down
payment on that plus a whole retention
package that truly values the work that
is being done in the NHS because without
a retention package recruitment initial
initiatives appointments because staff
are leaving and what we have to do is
invest in the workforce now to make sure
that the staff we've got now do not
leave and the NHS becomes a place where
people want to come and work but the
peer review body has told the government
what they think is appropriate and
that's what they've offered well the
pay-per-view body process was severely
delayed again so you know the first of
April is the end of tertiary date for
pay for NHS workers they didn't see that
pay award imposed into their pay packets
until September and October so what we
actually it was back dated to the first
of April but but what's not been spoken
about is that the lowest paid in the NHS
so so for us in the ambulance service
this is your call handle handlers it's
your patient Transport drivers they had
to have a Top-Up to their wages by NHS
employers so that they didn't reach
national minimum wage laws and what
we're going to see again this year is
exactly the same thing because the pay
review body process will not have been
followed through by April and what we
will see again is people for fall below
the national minimum wage that's
horrendous in the NHS these are the
people that we stood on our doorsteps
for and clapped for two years and now
they're the lowest paid in the country
it doesn't look as though the government
is budging I mean I I was chatting I'm
sure you heard what most of what the
health secretary was saying it doesn't
look associated
what are you gonna do
our members will decide we are a member
ledge Union and we you know we will
decide what what action looks like but
our members are not going to back down
on this they have had enough and the
strikes will continue as long as this
government allows them to so that's why
we're calling on the government to make
us an offer that we can take that to our
members they will be the ones that
decide if it's sufficient and they will
vote with their feet if this government
do not address their concerns now they
will continue to leave the service in
their thousands and that is what we're
seeing okay it's good to talk to you
Rachel I know you've got a very busy day
let us know how you get on when you keep
trying to speak to the government it's a
shame that we didn't have you both on
together quite entertaining wouldn't it
thank you okay bear with us one second
and somebody will help you out thanks
very much
um as I said these are live pictures
from up in Huddersfield this morning
where
members of the GMB Union call handlers
and um
ambulance drivers are taking the
opportunity to explain to the government
how frustrated they are at the pay offer
that has been given to them with no new
offer it would seem in the pipeline
Amanda is here now looking equally as
glamorous as our lovely friend from the
GMB Union so
where are we going to go with us well I
think what you got there from Rachel
Harrison from the GMB was this real
sense of the bitterness of it I mean it
almost feels like industrial relations
are at a new low today I think after the
kind of softer tone we were getting
after all those meetings on Monday the
unions are accusing Grant chaps of
mistruths over this crucial argument in
the anti-strike legislation he gave the
example of ambulance ambulance workers
not being willing to give minimum
service guarantees across the whole
country as the nurses has done as a kind
of key example a justification for why
this anti-strike legislation is needed
he said it's a question of Public Safety
and is is currently the case in other
European countries but what the unions
are saying is that's not true there were
agreements in place in local areas
across the country for the most serious
cause and they say it's an outrageous
attack on them to suggest that it's
their unions who've been putting
people's knives at risk they argue it's
the government that means minimum
service levels haven't haven't been
reached
um which of course we're seeing with the
long delays for treatments in the NHS
already
um we've heard those shocking figures
about the excess deaths over the past
year we know before Christmas for
example there were 1600 excess deaths in
just one weeks in one week we know that
doctors unions for example
um suggesting that they believe between
three and five hundred people are dying
each week because of delays in receiving
Emergency Care those figures are
disputed by the NHS and the government
but the very fact we're talking about
unions putting lives at risk the
government's saying they're trying to
defend that
um I think that shows the bitterness of
it all after on Monday when we had a bit
of a conciliation in the sense of this
at least wages and the the question of
you know what money is being offered
that did seem to be at least on the
table I think it was interesting Steve
Barkley when you were speaking to him
earlier was striking a slightly less
confrontational tone I think Grant
shapes that he's been the one in the
meetings with with the health unions he
said the characters well yes I mean he
was saying he had been working
constructively with the unions to try
and reach agreements
um but equally also said well I've you
know been up all night you know trying
to take calls to make sure we we've got
agreements in place where we can
um he wouldn't
give you a straight answer when you ask
what would happen if workers refused uh
to go to work under this new law which
effectively labor say well that means
workers would be sacked um if if that
that was the case and that's why they're
arguing that it's an attack on workers
on the right to strike so very
complicated okay we've got your take
coming up at nine o'clock looking
forward to that thanks so much indeed
thank you
now all week Sky News has been launching
the Westminster accounts it's a major
project with tortoise media which for
the first time details in one place how
much MPS are receiving in extra income
gifts and donations and from whom today
we're talking about the all-party
Parliamentary groups also known as appgs
while they have no official status
within Parliament they still get plenty
of money in donations here's our Deputy
political editor some coats whether
you're lobbying for a bank a religion or
a nation-state
appgs might not be well known but they
are big business
20 million pounds has been funneled into
them over the course of this Parliament
alone most of that goes on paying for
organizers reports research events and
trips and there are plenty of these
appgs to put money into
753 active groups that's more of them
than there are sitting members of
parliament
and these are the ones that are getting
the most money so many different
subjects covered here in just the top
five banking Christianity leveling up
Tech and artificial intelligence there's
an appg for every sector and every cause
and this is where the money is coming
from names you've probably never heard
of but what they say they do is
revealing of the top 10 six of these
companies are registered for lobbying
and many others have a clear agenda
well you can watch today's full report
from Sam on our website and throughout
the day here on Sky News let's talk
about it in more details should we lord
Eric pickles the chair of the
Parliamentary advisory committee on
business appointments is with us now
hello to my Lord thank you for joining
us on the program this morning uh what
sort of problems can arise from close
relationships between the government and
the private sector
if we're talking about the fppgs this is
about um uh offering uh Finance to move
things uh together in Parliament and to
offer policy my concern is this is a
good way for somebody to influence uh
Parliament uh in terms of how they put
the reports out but it's um I mean as
you as your question suggests it's a
good thing that they do this but I think
that that we um we haven't entirely
caught up uh with the process of
scrutinizing them there was a recent
select committee the express worries uh
suggested that it should be kind of a
gatekeeper the government's concede
there's a problem and I think it would
be rather nice if we got ahead of the
process now and did something about it
to avoid future problems
one of the ways Iran I suppose would be
potentially for member for the House of
Commons to be financing these appgs they
don't often receive any uh direct
financial support from Parliament do
they so does it matter at this stage if
they do get money from lobbying groups
if they're not getting it from where
perhaps they would initially think that
they would
I don't think it matters that they're
getting money from lobbying groups what
I think the important thing is and I
think we should take a leave from the
the stuff that you've been doing with
tortoise is it's a transparency that's
really important and I think we need to
have a a very clear idea of um of who's
financing that they appear on the
register uh in Parliament but I think we
need to have a an understanding of of
what their agenda is that could be that
the majority of these organizations are
altruistic and are simply wanting to a
further democracy
I'm not entirely sure where their House
of Commons would find the money to to
give this kind of finance and I don't
think it's a bad thing that money comes
to support politics outside the state
should MPS be taking money from foreign
governments so that they can travel
there
that's also very difficult uh a question
and it often it depends on what
government or in the United States
operates a very good system to
familiarize their new MPS with the
United States a number of other
countries do that but there are certain
countries in the world which you really
wouldn't want to take any money from
and in particular that you'd like to
highlight
I don't think God I don't think I'd like
to be drawn on that but I think your
viewers can take the Common Sense on
that but I think providing
we just need to have a greater degree of
transparency and uh that's why I think
what you've been producing has been uh
are so important I mean I've tried to
increase the amount of transparency in
my own uh organizations there's much
more detail out there and I think if you
explain
um it doesn't become uh you it's it's a
way of ensuring that what's going on is
proper but it's also ensuring that you
can avoid uh conspiracy theories as well
yeah I mean you find yourself
um in a in a I was going to say a bit of
a pickle but I'm not going to say that
um it won't be the first time someone
said that to me my apologies
um it looked as though you potentially
Fallen foul of the rules but you were of
course um subsequently uh cleared there
was a complaint major against you by a
member of the public as far as Oakwood
Services Limited was concerned it and
and you know you were perfectly within
the rules but it just goes to show how
how complex it can be to stay on the
right side of those rules
it is complex and that's why I took the
decision when I took on the job of agapa
that I would remove all paid um outside
interests and that I I wouldn't engage
because I didn't think it was
wasn't a requirement of the office but I
would have been uncomfortable I think
doing that if I would continue to work
with other outside organizations
okay I just wanted to go back on those
countries if I made there I mean as as
we're chatting it crossed my mind we
know that for example the previous prime
minister a previous prime minister we've
had quite a few in the last few months
Theresa May you know she went to Saudi
Arabia
um would you say that that was a country
that that perhaps uh
people shouldn't travel to at the moment
and then I was thinking maybe Iran where
do you stand on that or North Korea or
perhaps even Afghanistan
well serious numbers of numbers of
parliament who can't go to Iran they've
been banned I've been banned from uh
from from Russia people are banned from
from China in Saudi Arabia is an ally
and I think every I think individual
members of parliament or whether the
common sense need to be able to justify
what they're doing
uh and that just seemed a sensible
process and I I don't think the um the
parliament itself should impinge on what
members of parliament doing providing
members of parliament stand up and
um uh kind of um can justify
um their involvement with uh traveling
to another country
um another former prime minister Boris
Johnson earning an absolute fortune on
the um speaking circuit at the moment so
he seems to be incredibly popular
um do you think he should potentially be
the next prime minister for the
conservatives
well um that's out of my purview I don't
have a vote until it comes out but do
you have a video membership uh yes I do
I mean yeah I um great admire of Boris
but um I'm a great admirer of the
present prime minister and there is no
vacancy
[Laughter]
my Lord
it's got you as always thank you very
much love to talk to you as well thank
you uh QR code for the Westminster
accounts on screen now to use our Search
tool and discover how much money your MP
receives it's all in the Westminster
accounts from Sky News and tortoise
media
no it's a time of year when many people
love to go skiing apparently but instead
of groomed white pistes many of Europe's
most popular mountain resorts are still
green France Germany Switzerland and
Italy have all recorded record high
temperatures this winter which climate
scientists want could be a sign of
things to come let's bring in Claire
Irvin shatricia ahead of travel at the
times and the Sunday Times oh okay I'll
introduce my other guest as well
Jonathan Bamberg professor of Earth
observation and glaciology will come to
him in a short while but first let's
bring in Claire talk to us about what
it's like where you are at the moment
Claire good morning
morning well you can see here English
Stars uh we have snow
um we've had snow for two days though so
that's quite um a truncated season the
um when I'm here at a summit and when
many of the guests arrived over the
weekend from America this was completely
green and uh they were really lucky that
um they they awoke on their first
morning and actually it had snowed but
um yeah I mean normally you know you
know in past ski Seasons you would
expect snow for mid-December
um for that really busy key ski season
over the Christmas period and for these
Resorts that just rely on that that
tourist trade and for you know skiers
who really love the sport and for whom
their annual ski holiday has become you
know so important how is it affecting
skiing pontus more generally because you
said when they got that if they'd been
there last week they wouldn't have been
able to ski would they so what's it
doing to the business
well I mean in many ways ski holidays
have been quite one-dimensional in that
uh on other holidays you might go with
several activities that you uh you were
looking forward to doing with skiing is
very very focused you want to get on
those slots and ski down them so um so
obviously it's meaning that holiday
makers are having to be a lot more
flexible
um they might want you know their ski
resorts are offering things like
mountain biking and hiking and you know
walking in these really beautiful
surrounds but of course that isn't
necessarily the adrenaline fix that um
so many skiers want and of course it's
really expensive to go skiing so that is
a very big blow if you have bought all
of your um or very significant holiday
budget into that trip and then you can't
do what you went to to to go for
what's your advice for anyone who has a
holiday booked and has seen some of the
pictures that we put it on screen where
you can just see green slopes no snow at
all um do they still go is there
compensation do they can you take out
insurance for that
so there are lots of different Insurance
packages available but I have to say the
ones for which you can reclaim your
entire holiday are few and far between
um if at all in existence you can claim
and you would need to check the um the
small print very carefully firstly if
you're traveling with the job operator a
ski specialist many of them including um
two operators like Crystal have
um a promise that if there's no snow for
piece of clothes in the resort they've
sent you to they will get you to another
Resort within two hours where there is
snow of course those claims are um are
made or were made before Seasons like
this where lots of results are suffering
so that that's the first thing to
operator
um second is is insurance check the fine
print you insurers will pay back for
um days lost skiing but you need to make
sure that you fulfill all the um all the
criteria so you often need to have in
writing that the piece were closed there
needs to be a certain
um you know there needs to be literally
no snow for that to happen for many so
be very very certain what you're signing
up to in terms of your tour operator and
your insurance before you sign on the
dotted line because okay you could pick
yourself in a ski resort with no skiing
and no form of recompense okay um Claire
um thanks very much indeed it looks
beautiful behind you it has to be said
thanks very much for joining us let's
bring in Jonathan bambo should be
professor of Earth observation and
glaciology at the University of Bristol
and the University of Munich hello to
you uh Professor is this going to
continue on for future years is this the
norm now in other words
um well look if you warm the planet you
melt snow and ice it's that simple and
um I mean one one extreme year is not a
sign of a trend but you know we're
seeing so many of the extreme so many of
these extremes we saw unprecedented
flooding in Pakistan last year was the
warmest year on record in Europe and the
Arctic and so unfortunately this is this
is a trend that's just going to continue
um what should be so basically skiing in
the Alps is going to be a thing of the
past in the next decade or so
well look actually the snow conditions
above 2000 meters are still reasonable
and you know you can still ski in those
areas
um but the the snow level the lower
level is just going to go up and up and
up so don't be Glacier skiing
um at high altitude uh for maybe for
decades but you know it's going to
become increasingly difficult for ski
resorts to make this financially viable
and it's exactly what Claire said
um they're going to have to diversify
their offerings because uh snow is going
to become less sure every season now
yeah un said yesterday the ozone layer
is starting to heal though so why why is
this happening
so ozone
ozone's not the same as as climate
change or global warming Global heating
uh Global heating is due to CO2
emissions greenhouse gases that we're
emitting by burning fossil fuels that's
that's slightly different from ozone
um and you know we've seen since the
Industrial Revolution
um a global temperature increase of
about 1.2 degrees but actually it's
worse in Europe and and the Arctic and
so things you know things are are in a
pretty bad state in terms of
um Glacier what's called mass balance
that's how fast the glasses are melting
across Europe and slow cover in the
Arctic and
um the Alps
okay so
um from what you're saying um skiing is
going to be
probably a thing of the past in the next
two decades or so
um you're gonna have to try a lot harder
to find places where there's there's
short snow that's uh that's the bottom
line I think this is absolutely is a
sign of
um things to come
much appreciated thank you
a lot of snow if you do want to go thank
you if you do want to go skiing
apparently there's a lot of snow up in
Scotland at the moment is what we are
being told so
um not always the case you can't always
plan on having snow in Scotland but I am
being told that that is the case at the
moment so don't head south head north
instead whatever you do stay with us for
the next hour because we've got Labor's
Bridget Phillipson with us in just a
moment ambulance workers are on strike
the health secretary says he's doing
everything he can to try to sort it out
is he stay tuned and find out
foreign